la libertad de prensa comprometida en
siete de cada diez países los datos de
reporteros Sin fronteras son demoledores
con el rojo la peor clasificación
teniendo gran parte del mapa de los 180
países analizados India o Turquía Ahora
son parte de esta categoría Estambul
tienen prisión a 47 periodistas mientras
que Rusia debido a la guerra en Ucrania
volvió a descender en el ranking al
puesto 164
hemos tenido que ayudar a decenas de
medios de comunicación que ahora están
en el exilio sobre todo en Europa para
que el periodismo ruso pueda seguir
Sobreviviendo
[Música]
medio oriente sigue siendo la región más
peligrosa para el ejercicio periodístico
mientras que por primera vez ningún país
de américa está en verde con México como
la nación con mayor número de
periodistas desaparecidos en el mundo el
85% de la población mundial ha
experimentado un recorte de su libertad
de expresión en los últimos cinco años
hay problemas particulares por ejemplo
en relación con el acoso en línea contra
mujeres periodistas las amenazas más
comunes son la desinformación la
propaganda política o los contenidos
falsos generados por la Inteligencia
artificial cuyos riesgos Todavía están
por descubrirse
comportamientos y prácticas como los de
los políticos en dos tercios de los
países clasificados
la nota positiva la pone Noruega que
mantiene la primera posición por séptimo
año seguido de Irlanda y